2021 saison 2 du colis de 19 marquée par
plusieurs épisodes
ce dupas sanitaires et des
manifestations anti passeront marqué les
esprits et tout commence le 29 avril
après qu emmanuel macron déclare ceci le
passé ni terre ne saurait être
obligatoire pour accéder au lieu de la
vie de tous les jours comme les
restaurants théâtres et cinémas il ne
sera jamais un droit d'accès qui
différencie les français un message qui
aurait pu en rester là sauf qu'un peu
plus de deux mois plus tard le même
emmanuel macron non seulement
rétropédale mais impose aussi la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants pour les personnels soignants
et non soignants des hôpitaux des
cliniques des maisons de retraite des
établissements pour personnes en
situation de handicap pour tous les
professionnels ou bénévoles qui
travaillent au contact des personnes
âgées ou fragiles y compris à domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attend le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux je suis dans les avions trains
et cars pour les longs trajets une
volte-face qui sera le point de départ
d'un mouvement de contestation massive
contre le past and tard d'après les
autorités jusqu'à deux cent trente sept
mille personnes manifestent dans toute
la france sur la journée du 7 août vers
en lui même castex vaqueront ont tous
dit il aura pas de passage terre pierre
laurin mais pas étendu au restaurant bio
nos reins mais pas après le 15 novembre
mènera mais la troisième dose ne sera
pas intégrée mensonges mensonges
mensonges qu'on peut pas être gouverné
par le mensonge faut arrêter au bout
d'un moment et deuxièmement c'est la
folie totale cette stratégie est écoutée
l'europe est la zone où il ya le plus de
contamination dans le monde mais on l'a
dit lui-même les deux tiers c'est la
zone où il ya le plus le tout vaccinal
où il ya le plus de passes à vittel
c'est un échec radical et donc on change
radicalement de stratégie et on regarde
ce qui marche dans le monde ce qui
marche annoncée la liberté c'est pas
c'est d'investir leur hôpital c'est de
laisser traiter les gens c'est pas la
folie actuelle le fond n'est debout et
on sera deux roues jusqu'au bout lors
une colère qui gagne aussi la guadeloupe
où la résistance aux passants des tarer
à la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants et les pompiers et le point de
départ d'une contestation sans précédent
parfois violentes au point que
l'exécutif envoie sur place une centaine
de gendarmes et de membres du gign des
revendications plus larges émergent par
la suite et la question de l'autonomie
de lille revient même sur la table alors
pour protester contre l'arrêt des
négociations avec l'état plusieurs
centaines de manifestants à parviennent
à entrer dans l'hémicycle du conseil
régional de guadeloupe le 23 décembre
nous ne sommes pas une minorité violente
nous sommes le peuple qui se lève tout
entier et nous n'en sommes qu'au début
pourtant vivent dans l'hexagone ou aux
antilles la contestation contre le past
and i ter et l'obligation vaccinale fait
face à une forme de mépris de la part du
gouvernement il y a une très grande
majorité de français qui s'est fait
vacciner ou a prévu de le faire dans les
prochaines semaines il y a des français
plus difficiles à convaincre que
d'autres et donc il faut échanger avec
eux ils et convaincre il s'agit d'une
infime minorité qui est dans
l'instrumentalisation de tout ça pour
des raisons politiques politiciennes
pour des raisons médiatiques qui joue
avec les peurs et racontent n'importe
quoi
le président de la république pour sa
part qualifie les manifestants d'égoïste
et d'irresponsables claude malhuret
sénateur indépendant de l'allier qui ne
fait jamais dans la demi mesure va
jusqu'à l'insultent en comparant les
manifestations anti passe à des cortèges
de pigeons menées par des ânes alors que
les résistants d'opérette s'exprimer
dans les rues avec leurs pieds tous les
autres français se sont exprimés avec
leur cervelle en se faisant vacciner ils
ne savent même pas localiser leur
vésicule biliaire mais ont un avis
tranché sur la rn messager et lead roxy
chloroquine malgré la colère qui monte
le gouverneur on ne recule pas il va
même plus loin en voulant transformer le
passé ni terre en passe vaccinale
objectif pousser les 6 millions de
réfractaires à se faire vacciner il
n'est pas admissible que le refus de
quelques millions de français de se
faire vacciner met en risque la vie de
tout un pays un projet de loi sera
soumis au parlement début janvier
notamment pour transformer le pass and i
ter en passe vaccinale et durcir les
conditions de contrôle et de sanction
contre les faux pas sanitaires désormais
seule la vaccination sera valable dans
le pass ce projet de passes vaccinale
doit être débattue à l'assemblée
nationale dans les premiers jours de
janvier avant d'être transmis au sénat
le gouvernement vise une application à
compter du 15 janvier d'ici là le
mouvement de contestation pourrait bien
repartir de plus belle